salut on attend la dernière ligne droite
pour cette série d'énigmes et on attend
aussi la dernière ligne droite de l'été
ouais je sais c'est moche
avant de vous donner l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui la réponse à l'énigme
d'hier si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme
d'hier allait la voir avant d'écouter la
réponse la réponse est huit jours
l'escargot atteindra le haut du mur au
bout du huitième jour et non pas du 10e
qui a la réponse spontanée qu'on croit
avoir au départ si vous faites bien le
dessin avec les montées de trois mètres
et les descentes vous allez vous
apercevoir qui va vous falloir huit
jours complets pour atteindre le haut du
mur et maintenant rangé les cagouilles
c'est parti pour l'énigme du genre cette
énigme numéro 24 est un test de
psychologie alors ça fait longtemps que
je connais ce test psychologie là j'ai
toujours entendu parler que c'était le
test pour détecter qu'il était
psychopathe ou pas j'ai fait des
recherches sur internet pour avoir la
source vraiment initial de ce test j'en
ai pas trouvé donc je me demande c'est
pas une espèce de légende urbaine sur le
fait que ce soit un test de psychopathe
en tout cas je trouvais ça intéressant
de vous poser ce test je vais vous le
dire directement pour être sûr de ne
rien oublier d'être très précis aux
funérailles de sa mère une jeune fille
rencontre un jeune homme qu'elle ne
connaissait pas elle le trouve
fantastique c'est l'homme de ses rêves
c'est le coup de foudre et elle tombe
très amoureuse de ce garçon n'a
toutefois elle ne lui a jamais demandé
ni son nom ni son numéro de téléphone et
elle ne peut pas trouver quelqu'un dans
son entourage qui le connaîtrai ankara
là en galère à la pâte lisse
quelques jours plus tard cette jeune
fille tu sa propre soeur question
pourquoi est ce qu'elle a tué sa soeur
réfléchissez à votre propre solution
pour cette énigme ne cherchait pas à la
connaître parce que demain avec la
réponse je vais vous donner des éléments
qui vont permettre de comprendre votre
propre réponse c'est hyper important si
vous avez une réponse faites le moi
savoir en mettant dans les commentaires
j'ai trouvé une solution et mettez un
pouce en l'air pour qu'on sache le
nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé une
piste où une solution on en parle de la
prochaine vidéo pensez à vous abonner
avant de partir et rendez vous demain à
17h ciao
et